It's time for Drew's News,
your good news booze
in the good news jacuzz.
And with me at the desk,
my trusty co-pilot and human cocktail, Rossy Ross Mathews.
(audience cheering)
I am, I am, hi, everybody!
I just threw that in.
Human cocktail.
You are a human cocktail.
Thank you, a little bubbly.
You are, you're as effervescent
as the most fine champagne there is.
I've always wanted to make a Rose Mathews that was like,
you know, extra bubbly and slightly fruity, you know?
(Drew laughing hysterically)
That's full bodied.
I'm like, "That's so funny.
When are we doing this?"
I know, right?
You know my business side
can't just hear an idea like that
and like let it pass by.
Extra bubbly and a little fruity,
that's what it should say on the bottle?
Exactly, yeah!
You've already got your campaign slogan.
All right, oh, this just in,
we just hold like a billion bottles.
Thank you so much, thank you so much.
Rightfully so, well, first up,
we are all going back to the movies again,
which is so exciting.
And I have to say a lot of people
have asked me personally like, "Where did the rom-com go?
Why are rom-coms not around?
We need them."
So listen to this.
There is a rom-com on its way.
George Clooney and Julia Roberts in "Ticket to Paradise."
It's not out to the fall,
but "People" reports that Julia says
it's the rom-com script
she's been waiting for since the '90s.
In the '90s, I mean,
she was making films like "Notting Hill,"
"My Best Friend's Wedding."
I mean, if anyone is an authority on rom-coms,
I feel like it is Julia Roberts.
Yeah, Julia Roberts and you, yes.
Uh-huh, yeah, of course.
Well, thank you
for saying that.
Well, it's the truth, hello?
(audience clapping)
Hello, icon.
I bow to her.
And George Clooney hasn't done a rom-com
since he did "One Fine Day" with Michelle Pfeiffer.
Which I've seen 100 million times.
Thank you so much.
Well, Julia says that she wasn't avoiding rom-coms,
she was just waiting for that one that was good enough,
and this is it.
And I will tell you, I would trust Julia Roberts
as an authority on rom-coms.
So boy am I excited!
I'm excited too.
And I love hearing the behind the scenes of how it happens,
'cause you speak from like the movie star POV.
Let me talk from the fan POV a little bit.
Julia Roberts, I need this movie, all right?
I have watched in the past, how many years has it been?
I sit and I watch "Notting Hill,"
pretending like I don't know exactly what's gonna happen
and that I can't quote these,
"I'm just a girl standing in front of a boy," right?
You know, how about "My Best Friend's Wedding"?
Is there a better movie than
"My Best Friend's Wedding"?
It's the best.
(audience clapping)
All right, next up.
Here's a story you actually brought to the desk, Drew.
It's about the incredible Billie Eilish.
(audience clapping)
Yes, I know.
We're all obsessed.
She's been tearing up the stage at Coachella.
And "VegNews" reports she's also found time
to collaborate with Nike.
This is the collaboration I did not see coming.
They asked Billie to give their iconic Air Force 1 sneakers
a sustainable makeover, right?
Which means make it more environmentally friendly.
And check these out,
these mushroom-colored kicks
are made entirely of vegan leather
and they're 100% recycled polyester.
Billie also designed a roomy, oversized sweatsuit to match.
Would you wear this, Drew?
Well, I'm so excited to show you them
live and in person.
What, you have them?
I didn't know we had them.
(audience clapping)
She is so capable of being a leader
and influencing her generation.
And the fact that she is this person,
and it's just time for all of us
to approach things differently,
there's just no one I love more than Billie Eilish.
And I'm so excited for her to do this,
because I think this could be the first of so much.
And this is all made with vegan leather
and that's all really environmentally friendly.
'Cause even some vegan leathers
are actually plastic that don't break down.
This is not that.
And I'm just so impressed with everything she does.
So thank you for bringing this.
And they're so cool.
So cool.
They're so cool.
(audience clapping)
I love that she's changing the sneaker game.
She's changing the sneaker game at like 20 years old.
At 20 years old, I was saving up to buy a pair of sneakers.
You know, like she's very impressive.
She really is on every single level.
Agreed.
She is just incredible.
So thank you, Billie,
for everything you do.
Yes, agreed.
(upbeat music)